now watch him get down it's a special
musical episode of the flash all new
Tuesday March 24 being a hero
falling in love they're hard and
sometimes they hurt
I've never seen a crazy like that in my
life
be careful
prince abduction this changes everything
well my friends I guess that is a wrap
on
whoever that is
everybody it's Charlie we got our
musical crossover so I'm gonna explain
what's going on let's break it down if
you're looking at this and you have no
idea what's going on you're like why is
there a musical crossover episode it's
actually two episodes it's episode 16 of
Supergirl next week and then the next
day episode 17 of the flash so what
happens is is the crossover part starts
at the end of Supergirl or really like
the last story arc where musikmeister
comes in puts the whammy on Supergirl
she goes into a coma where what you're
seeing is happening so all the musical
stuff like with them dancing around her
dressed up to look like Peggy Carter
Berry in the tuxedo looking like Fred
Astaire it's like this Fred Astaire
Ginger Rogers or you can really pick any
duo from that era really like Fred
Astaire Ginger Rogers is 1920s some-odd
era and then Peggy Carter is World War 2
era so that actually happened much later
so I think the time period this takes
place in is closer to 1930s 1940s
because it looks like you have some
gangsters there in the trailer but I
should say there's a new round of the
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video and actually just
a quick correction it's actually March
21st so it's not next week's episode
it's the week after that so it's in two
weeks so this is still a ways off but
the set up for this is pretty big so
Kevin Sorbo
and Teri Hatcher's characters are coming
onto Supergirl for a different arc and
while all that's going on in the chaos
musikmeister puts the whammy on
Supergirl I will explain what teri
hatcher and Kevin Sorbo are doing later
in this video but I'll put a spoiler
warning on it because it just happened
on Supergirl so then on the flash part
of the crossover Barry gets a visit from
MA Nell and Martian Manhunter who come
to earth one with Kara asking for help
she's under this crazy spell so then the
music Meister also puts the whammy on
the flash and he gets sucked into this
reality with Supergirl and the only way
for them to escape is to play by the
rules of the universe it's sort of like
a matrix type episode whereby he can't
just use his powers to get out so the
way they put it is is that life is like
a musical the only way to escape is to
follow the script so they have to do a
lot of singing dancing all the way to
the end of the episode so that sort of
explains the logic of why they're
singing through the episode so if you
haven't seen it there was about the
episode
once more with feeling the Joss Whedon
wrote whereby it's all like this magical
enchantment that causes them to sing for
the entire episode so it's a little in
the vein of that so it's just them
having a little bit of fun with the idea
in the music Meister character himself
did not start out in the comics he
actually started out on the Brave and
the bold TV show he was played by Neil
Patrick Harris then later he was adapted
to the comic book that was based on that
cartoon show so he was in The Brave and
the bold comic book but it's not the
main brave in the bold comic book it's
sort of like a roundabout way to get to
a character but it's one of those things
where a character like Harley Quinn for
instance did not start out in the comics
she was made for Batman the Animated
Series and then was adapted into the
comics so the same thing is happening
with a lot of characters nowadays -
there's just a lot of characters that
are debuting on TV that make it to the
comics later they've been posting behind
the scenes stuff if you guys didn't know
all three of these actors were on Glee
together at various points so it's sort
of a Glee reunion for them too but
there's a bunch of other people that
will be singing and dancing in the
episode they said that iris West is a
really big important part of the plot I
have no idea how that's gonna play out
they just said that she's very important
for the plot the people that they've
confirmed will have singing parts are
Jesse Martin Victor Garber John
Barrowman that's right Malcolm Merlyn is
going to be a part of the crossover
Jeremy Jordan in Carlos Valdes so what
they've done is they give it all the
characters who can sing and dance in
real-life parts like that in the
crossover so like Stephen Amell for
instance does not like to sing on camera
so he's not going to be a part of this
crossover but they did tease that like
in future years they might have more
people from the other shows do stuff
like this but whatever it is it's done
in full period so it'll be a lot of fun
that's why they want to make it feel
very different from modern day so it's
not like they're just gonna be walking
around on the streets singing the whole
time so we'll see how it goes I don't
know if they're gonna do this every year
because they do the four and I crossover
every year that's like an annual thing
just because it's so popular I think if
this does really well then they'll think
about doing it again next year with
slightly different characters but the
cool thing is is that they will have
Martian Manhunter on this part of the
crossover because he wasn't really a
part of the four night crossover the
whole deal with Kevin Sorbo and teri
hatcher is actually really cool it's
cool to see
her comeback on and he's done so much
John Ross tough that he is just going to
smash everything
Hercules smash I felt different yes
there's something about this place
your eyes
we've reached our coordinates
finally
we've arrived
[Music]
so it seems like the deal is is that
they are the king and queen of daksa and
they have come looking for Monell who is
likely the Prince of Dax Emmet has been
lying to Supergirl about his identity so
the title of next week's Supergirl is
star-crossed as in star-crossed lovers
Romeo and Juliet sort of like the
Montagues and the Capulets in the way
that they talk about Dax 'im and Krypton
being hated enemies of each other so
that's what's going on with them they're
supposed to be on for a three episode
arc I think so all the crossover stuff
is happening they'll be all this teri
hatcher Kevin Sorbo stuff happening in
the background to really the bump part
in all this is Kevin Sorbo squeezing his
hand like he's getting his Hercules
powers back because of Earth's Yellow
Sun so think of it as like a New Krypton
type of arc from the comics like they're
just gonna come and terrorize people for
a couple episodes so let me know what
you guys think about all this remember
it's not gonna be happening for a couple
more weeks
like next week's episode of the flash
after the breath of Savitt are is called
in to the Speed Force so it's not gonna
have anything to do with the musical
crossover that's two weeks down the road
but we got a new Wonder Woman dropping
we got a new flash episode later tonight
so I'll post that stuff after it drops
be sure to check it out it's gonna be a
really crazy episode of the flash - well
you pay for that you can click here for
that Wonder Woman trailer I'll update
the link as soon as I post it and you
can click here for my Logan Easter eggs
thank you so much for watching
let's hop up I'll see you guys in the
next video